tonight special counsel robert muller
already has memos from the fired FBI
director james comey and now his fire
deputy director Andrew McCabe as the
political fallout grows a source close
to the fired FBI deputy director
confirms he documented his conversations
with President Trump where he often
raised McCabe's wife and her
unsuccessful 2015 Virginia Senate race
jill mccabe received more than $600,000
from democrats including then Governor
Terry McAuliffe a longtime Clinton ally
the FBI said the campaign contributions
were not a conflict because it was
before McCain took the helm of the
Clinton email case but critics say the
contributions showed bad judgment and
McCain's termination for cause undercuts
his credibility I don't think it's any
big deal I'm sure the president Trump
never said anything to Andrew McCabe
that was illegal or implying any type of
a gala T so you can keep all the memos
he wants to turn them over President
Trump who praised McCabe's firing as a
great day for the FBI emphasized that he
spent very little time with the FBI's
former number-two insinuating McCabe
drafted the memos to help his own agenda
one senior Republican called for public
hearings to show whether McCabe's
termination was suspect coming two days
before his government's pension kicked
in when it comes to this issue we need
as much transparency as possible to make
sure it wasn't politically motivated Fox
News has learned the FBI branch then
investigates misconduct allegations
began looking at McCabe as early as last
summer the grounds for termination go
beyond media leaks the Inspector General
concluded McCabe lacked candor on
multiple occasions FBI veterans who want
the Inspector General to make the
evidence public as soon as possible say
Bureau rules online
our strict lack of candor potentially
gets you fired that that expectation
applies to the the brand-new FBI agent
and it should apply to the deputy
director a senior House Democrat
indicated McCabe's firing may be
justified but he remains concerned about
a broader pattern a half-dozen of
director Comey's closest associates
including former general counsel James
Baker chief of staff James Wright Viki
senior agent Peter struck lawyer Lisa
Paige Media Chief Mike Gorton have
retired been fired reassigned or demoted
is this because the
corroborate james comey that's a
question we also have to answer in his
statement McCabe said director Comey
knew about his contact with the media
which observer said appears to conflict
with the former directors testimony days
before he got fired have you ever sung
one else at the FBI to be an anonymous
source in news reports about the Trump
investigation or the Clinton
investigation no the Inspector General's
report could come at any time but in
recent weeks two sources tell Fox News
new leads were pursued and new
interviews conducted breath Kevin thank
you Mark